- It was just supposed to say,
"Who love orange soda?"
"Kel loves orange soda."
I T-Pained it and I doo-oo doo doo on it,
to now people are stopping
me on the street. (laughs)
(bell rings)
(tea pouring)
(electronic music)
(laughs)
Kenan, of course.
We would always try to
make each other laugh.
One of the times we both just cracked up
at a live show, and they kept it.
Nickelodeon actually kept it.
I think I took a burger
and turned it into a shake.
I turned back around,
and Kenan just broke.
And, then I broke.
And we both started cracking up laughing.
(electronic music)
Coach Kreeton was a lot of fun
just because he does a
lot of physical comedy,
and I knew I'd get to tear up the place.
Tear up the set and scream.
I love physical comedy,
and anytime I can get really physical
I love those moments.
(electronic music)
Amanda, okay.
Her talent is amazing.
Her physical comedy.
She was never scared to get physical.
And they were like,
"She wants to do physical
comedy like how you do,"
and I just gave her a lot of pointers.
She took it and ran with it.
She's a beast.
She's fearless. So, I liked
all of Amanda's scenes.
She was another one that
was really fun to watch.
Amanda, what's up girl?
I see you.
(electronic music)
The friendship, cause that's
where it initially started.
And hanging out.
And they were like, "This
needs to be a show."
Having fun and having your friend's back.
Yeah, that's definitely like me.
As far as the other crazy
stuff that he would do,
how he would mess up
stuff, not me so much.
I love playing that character, man.
He's just awesome, yeah.
(electronic music)
It's between "Welcome to Good Burger,"
and "Who loves orange soda?"
Anywhere I go I'm treated
like the Burger King.
If I order anything at a restaurant,
and it's not orange soda,
"You're supposed to be
drinking orange sodas!"
Don't be scared to come up and ask me,
if you see me in person,
and talk about orange soda and burgers.
I'm not gonna spill the
orange soda in your face.
It's all good.
(electronic music)
Oh, I drinked a lot of orange soda on set.
And it wasn't like just little bottles
or cans of orange soda.
I mean, these were liters
that I would just be chugging.
Like, just hitting it.
Chugging, chugging.
That's when I would just do anything.
They were like, "Kel just does anything!"
Well, I have a lot of
fructose inside of me.
(electronic music)
That's a good one.
The conversations have started.
There's something in the water.
Everything's coming back.
It would definitely be awesome,
and there was a meeting.
They're just working out
everything contractually.
So, just keep your ears to the streets.
(electronic music)
I would say just have fun, man.
Enjoy it.
I was ready to battle.
I just had the heart of a lion.
Like, I was like this every sketch.
"I'm about it make it the
funniest thing you never seen."
I would say just have a
little bit more fun with it
but also still keep that intensity
because it definitely worked.
We'll have a bottle of orange soda,
and just hang out and chill.
What up Kell?
What's up Kell?
You good?
I'm good.
You gonna be just amazingly handsome,
and you're still gonna stay the same.
You're gonna be great, man.
Just stay right.
Eat the right foods.
(laughing)
(electronic music)
(sign creaking)